I have sort of a oddball documentary
recommendation today hear me out okay
and Lois I know you're gonna have a
reaction to this the documentary is Tony
Robbins I am NOT your guru I'm leaving
I'm out of here that's it this is a
documentary about this life coach
motivational speaker call him what you
want Tony Robbins huge huge guy had a
pituitary gland tumor I believe when he
was a kid he's huge he has huge hands
and and etc etc and he's sort of known
for his his physical presence he also is
a very very good public speaker one of
the most gifted public speakers maybe of
the last couple of decades certainly
English language the documentary follows
him behind the scenes of this seminar he
does called date with destiny where 2500
people show up I think they pay five or
seven thousand dollars each to go and as
I watched it there's no doubt that this
is a compelling great speaker who is
able to inspire and get reactions from
people he's very good at reading people
on the fly but I couldn't determine
whether this entire thing this business
he built which has given him a net worth
reportedly of around four hundred and
fifty million dollars is this guy
charlatan I mean is he a showman or is
he actually helping people and I don't
really know the answer
Louis and I've shown this documentary to
a few people many of whom are sort of in
the in the mental health world and they
say you know he's clearly very good at
connecting with people but what he's
doing is certainly not therapy and in
his defense he doesn't claim that what
he's doing is therapy but is he really
helping people long-term I don't I don't
know the answer the interesting thing
about gurus and I would recommend
simultaneously here a documentary called
Kumar a right although to be clear Tony
Robbins doesn't claim to be a guru
that's fine that's fine so the point is
that whether or not he believes that he
is helpful to people or that he has some
incredible insight and or that he is I
don't even know how you'd word it that
he's supposed to help people even if he
doesn't believe any of that as long as
the people that he's speaking to are are
bettered by it
yeah then he is helping people and and
in Kumar a it's a guy who fakes being
this spiritual guru doesn't believe any
of the nonsense he says he's
deliberately doing it as a goof just to
see what the reaction will be is right
but he actually ends up helping many
people and it's uh it's very interesting
and so it's really that the power of
one's mind to to convince themselves
that they're being helped but you don't
have to have some base level of skills
right I mean you did reason Tony Robbins
is able to even make people react in
this way to him and feel as though he's
incredibly insightful and useful to them
is partially that he is such a good
speaker no doubt no doubt he has a
particular skill set and and that is
necessary of course I will remind you we
are talking about the documentary Tony
Robbins I am NOT your guru it is on
Netflix I didn't find it on Amazon but
you can check this and all of my other
recommendations out at david pakman.com
slash recommendations